hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be looking at a nice little
middlegame tactic called the deflection
what deflection is is anytime your
opponent is using one of his pieces to
do too many things you want to try to
deflect or move that piece so that one
of his rolls is no longer being used and
in this case if you look at it looks
like a very draw position both sides
have the equal number of pawns they both
have a queen in a rook it's White's move
here but white realizes that black has
this rook on da and this rook on d8 is
doing too many things it's defending
this back rank and at the same time it's
defending this Queen on d6
so if somehow we can deflect this rook
off of the d8 protecting this Queen on
d6
then we can capture with our queen and
what we can do is use deflection by rook
to e8 as you can see here we're
attacking this King at the same time he
has to retake if he moves his King then
we can retake and we're going to be up
in significant material if he doesn't
however if instead he does take with his
rook then this rook that was on d8
defending this Queen is no longer
defending it we deflected it to the e8
square and now we can easily take his
queen on d6 and as you can tell we won
that exchange and whites from here are
now going to have a very easy win so
that's what you want to think about as
we look through these examples is you
want to find a weakness in your
opponent's position where one of his
pieces is doing too much and you want to
deflect that away so that you can
capitalize on that so let's look at a
few more examples let's take a look at
another example here and it's White's
move and pause the video if you need to
but find White's best move in this
situation
and hopefully you saw that the queen is
only protected by this King here on f7
and this is a lot of the things that you
should be looking for in a chess game
what Square or what pieces are defended
by what and what can you do to deflect
those pieces away from defending the
piece or square that you want to occupy
in this case we want to dominate this e
seven Queen and so we're going to do
this by bringing our rook to G seven and
we're deflecting this King when he is
forced to make a decision if he moves
then we're going to take it with our
queen and he's not going to have a rook
if he takes it with his rook which we
really don't care if he does or not then
the e seven square is no longer
protected and we can take it with our
queen so we deflected the King to the g7
square via our rook and then the Queen
was no longer being protected so we
could bring it in with our queen on e
seven so let's go ahead and take a look
at a few more examples let's take a look
at another example here and it's White's
move and try to find White's best move
in this situation
and hopefully you saw that whites main
goal here is to take this pawn on h4 and
then bring his Queen to h7 followed by a
checkmate depending on how long black
wants to avoid the inevitable but as you
can see here the main problem that white
has is this Queen on d8 and so our goal
is to deflect that away from the d8
squared we're going to do that by
bringing our rook to b8
and black has a decision he can leave it
on this eighth-ranked and lose his queen
or he can move it along this diagonal
and we can take it with our knight or
our Bishop depending on where he moves
it and if he does take it as you can see
already we can bring our Queen to h4 and
then subsequently we can bring our Queen
to h7 depending on whatever his moves
are he can bring his Queen down to b2 if
he wants to you know prolong the game
depending on what he does though it's
going to be checkmate very soon as you
can see here we gave up a rook but it
doesn't matter because all we really
wanted was to bring our Queen to h4 and
not have him be harassed by this Queen
on da so let's go ahead and take a look
at one more example about deflection and
then we'll go ahead and wrap it up the
last example we're going to look at is a
pretty complicated problem if you've
never seen it before it's probably the
most famous deflection problem that
you've ever seen if you've ever taken a
look at deflection problems it actually
comes from a real game taking place in
1920 so if you want to try to attempt
and figure it out on your own go ahead
and pause it right now but I'm going to
go ahead and get into the solution if
you look at it white realizes that he
has a mate on e8 if this Queen or this
rook from c8 are not there if we were to
take this Queen and put it elsewhere
let's put them on g4 then you can
automatically see in your head that once
our rook takes on e8 and he retakes with
his rook on c8 and we have an easy
checkmate the same thing if this rook is
gone then once we take on EA with our
rook it's
to be an easy checkmate so our goal is
to deflect either the queen or the rook
away from d7 or c8 and if we do that
then we're going to win the game via
this checkmate on e8 so our first goal
and our first move is going to be Queen
to g4 it's a very important move and
we're trying to deflect this coin away
from the d7 scores you can already see
as we talked about before if he does
take then it's going to be an easy
checkmate for white here so he can't do
that instead his best move he can't come
to c6 because we can take it and he
can't come to a4 because we'll just take
it so his best move again he has to
defend this eh square so his best move
is going to be to come to b5 and from
here we're going to bring our Queen to
c4 again we're trying to have black take
with either his queen or his rook in
this case it doesn't matter if he takes
with this rook because it'll be the same
thing we'll take with our rook and he
has to capture with this Queen and then
it's going to be good game from here so
as you can see it doesn't matter for us
if we can get this Queen to stop
defending the e8 square or this rook to
stop defending the e8 square we're going
to win the game so that's all we're
trying to do this entire time so from
here blacks really only move again he
can't come to a4 because we'll just take
with our queen he can't come back to c6
because we'll take with our pawn so he's
going to move back to the 7 where he
originally started with but we're in a
little different position than we were
before so we're going to continue along
with our plan and now we're going to
bring our Queen to c7 as you can see
here we're just asking black to take it
with you there's Queen ORS rook it
doesn't matter which one he takes it
with we're just trying to deflect it off
of protecting this g8 square
so as black already knows if he does
this he loses so we can't do this so
he's going to bring his queen back to b5
still trying to hold on to this eh
square we're going to bring our pawn to
a4 we're just trying to completely
harass this Queen on b5 and after he
takes we're now going to bring our rook
to e4 again we're just asking black to
take because if he takes then we're
going to have an easy win we can now
take with our rook and then if he
retakes then we're going to have
checkmate right here if he takes with
this rook then we're going to have
checkmate right here so either way he
loses if he takes with his rook excuse
me if he takes this rook on e4 so we
can't do that so he's going to bring his
Queen back to b5 he still has his rook
and his Queen attacking the e8 square
defending it and so we're going to bring
our queen to b7 and this is going to be
the deciding move right here black can
go ahead and resign there's nothing
black can do to hold on to this ei
square his Queen can't go anywhere this
Queen comes to a 4 we'll take it with
our rook if he comes to c6 we can take
it with our pawn or queen maybe comes to
d7 we can take it with our Queen and as
we already looked at before if he does
move his Queen off of this diagonal and
it's no longer protecting the e8 square
he's going to lose the game so from here
black can go ahead and resign good game
black and well done white if you somehow
found this on your own that's awesome
you are a deflection genius but this is
kind of how you can use deflection this
there was a lot of deflection moves in
this but it really shows you if you have
an idea or square or a piece that you
really want to I on think about what's
protecting it and think about how you
can deflect that defender away from that
piece or that square so hope you guys
enjoyed the video on deflection if you
haven't already please subscribe and
check out the website WWE test website
comm pretty easy and I will see you guys
in the
next video thanks for watching